сьогодні дуже важливий день коли святиня
українського народу києво-печерська
лавра має бути позбавлена впливом
Московської церкви позбавлена
присутності та Московської церкви коли
було отримано томос коли президент
Порошенко і команда все священництво
українське домоглися того що Україна
отримала свою незалежну автокефальну
православну церкву України вже стало
тоді питанням часу коли українські
святині мають бути позбавлені
Московської присутності перейти до
українського народу і там має
відбуватися молитви Української церкви
Дуже хотілось би щоби сьогодні справді
цей процес розпочався а для московських
попів повідомлення одне і дуже просте та
маскую 850 км а зараз того ближче